et
il
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis vraiment ravi
d'être là parmi vous ce soir pour vous
parler de ce nouvel art du pouvoir un
doux valeur du pouvoir dont je veux
partager trois caractéristiques clés ce
soir avec vous avant ça je vais vous
dire pourquoi je suis là c'est avant
tout grâce à guy qui va croiser dans un
couloir en octobre 2000 dans un cabinet
des big five et qui m'a proposé un
projet très très audacieux il savait mes
valeurs il connaissait aussi mon goût
pour les projets de conduite du
changement ardue et alors il m'a proposé
un challenge fantastique amener du soft
power dans une culture de la performance
et du up out
j'étais chargé en fait
ne proposait à des partenaires
essentiellement des hommes de conduire
des actions spécifiques à destination
des femmes
pour qu'elle arrête de s'arrêter aux
portes du leadership
alors la question est bien plus grande
que ce que vous imaginez j'ai pas mon
bipper elle est bien plus large que ce
que vous imaginez ça va bien au delà de
l'équilibré vie privée les
professionnels en fait ce que j'ai
découvert lors tous mes entretiens
c'est qu'il s'agissait surtout
d'apporter un nouveau modèle de pouvoir
de leadership
waouh il fallait une annonce ça
vous imaginez bien alors l'idée ça a été
des impliqués
je leur ai proposé une idée folle je
leur ai proposé de les rencontrer un à
un tous ses partenaires et de leur
demander finalement en 2005 2010 on
était en 2000 qu'est ce que vous
imaginez qu'un leader devra avoir comme
compétence
et qu'est-ce qu'il faudra à vos leaders
nos équipes sur les projets pour pouvoir
être bon
alors puisque je les projeter dans le
business ils ont été vraiment vraiment
créatif et m'ont proposé vraiment
beaucoup de choses et m'ont proposé un
des caractéristiques tellement large que
ça pouvait convenir à la fois aux hommes
et aux femmes
donc nous aboutissions à une proposition
totalement win win un changement à
partir de là pouvaient concrètes
possibles mais au-delà de ça aulas que
burke ou d'autres chercheurs épuré
aurait pu qualifier de valeurs féminines
ou valeurs masculines
je découvre est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus important et aussi
d'ailleurs
le leader de demain telle qu'il
l'imaginait était loin d'être le super
héros qui sait tout et qui peut tout
c'était un leader à l'ecoute un leader
beaucoup plus collectif
un leader beaucoup plus responsabilisant
et ça ça me plaisait vraiment beaucoup
alors j'ai passé trois années
magnifiques de ma vie avec eux à
promouvoir ce nouveau type de leader
jusqu'à ce qu'une coach avec lequel on
travaille sur le projet me propose un
autre projet fantastique celui de
l'accompagner à créer un projet pour
mettre en cohérence les valeurs
personnelles et professionnelles des
acteurs de changement qui dans
l'entreprise essayer de promouvoir
quelque chose d'autre de faire en gros
ce qu'elle avait fait avec moi
l'expérience a tourné court
mais j'avais trouvé ce vers quoi tous
mes choix avec concorder j'avais trouvé
ma raison d'être
et ça c'était d'accompagner les leaders
dans le rôle déterminant qu'il joue dans
la transformation
alors
qu'est ce que j'ai fait il franchit le
pas j'ai créé mon entreprise et je me
suis décidé à lui ouvrir toutes les
portes de ses grandes organisations pour
accueillir et pour recueillir sur tous
les besoins de tous ces leaders de
changement alors comme j'avais 30 ans
forcément les drh m'a regardé et m'a
demandé un peu de prouver qu est ce que
je pouvais apporter mais c'était pas
grave j'avais ce bagage de trois années
fantastiques d'une mine une révolution
culturelle trois années de coaching
aussi derrière moi et puis surtout j'ai
eu un petit coup de pouce du destin
une autre de mes passions l'écriture ma
plume et une rencontre une rencontre
avec mon premier patron du cac 40
je me suis planté devant lui et je lui
ai simplement demandé s'ils pouvaient
témoigner dans mon livre
après quelques minutes des changes il
m'a dit oui mais à une condition la
condition c'était qu'ils soient pas tout
seul qui en est d'autres bien sûr pas de
problème je m'étais engagé un petit peu
8 est à la fois j'avais ma promesse à
tenir alors j'y suis allé j'y suis allé
et j'ai découvert un monde fantastique
je suis rentré dans un autre monde que
le mien et puis ça allait plus j'avais
envie de découvrir ce monde et j'ai eu
de la chance on m'a fait confiance
mon premier patron du cac qui m'a
présenté son équipe fait travailler avec
elle puis avec son top 50
et là je pénétrai encore tout autre
chose les arcanes du pouvoir
or les arcanes du pouvoir quand on les
regarde de loin ça fait un peu peur
forcément il ya tout ce qu'on n'aime pas
trop voir les agendas super charger les
voyages les jeux de pouvoir les jeux de
personnes les jeux d'ego mais il ya
aussi ce qui est à côté
cette formidable expérience qu'on a de
pouvoir changer l'entreprise de pouvoir
mobiliser les gens de pouvoir donner du
sens à des milliers de personnes et ça
c'est vraiment extraordinaire
alors j'ai enrichi cette étude du
leadership pour arriver à une nouveau
paradigme dont je vais vous parler ce
soir
le paradigme du leader collectif
leader collectif ça semble un peu
antinomique leader fort collectif à
tilly collective ensemble est ce que
c'était vraiment paradoxal non
je pouvais m'en souvenir à chaque
instant j'avais moi même eu des
expériences où ils ont montré qu'on
pouvait avoir du leadership est à la
fois jouer collectif quand je m'étais
retrouvé par exemple devancé 40 managers
et senior manager qui nous aidaient sur
le projet je leur ai proposé une méthode
au complètement différent de ce qu'ils
avaient l'habitude je leur avais dit ok
je vais pas vous donner de solution je
vais pas vous faire de proposition je
vais juste vous donner un problème le
nôtre en commun et je vais vous donner
un cadre de réflexion pour juste donner
des bornes à votre imagination et ce qui
est sorti tout ça c'était vraiment
extraordinaire
j'aurais jamais imaginé qu'en deux
heures de temps on fasse un plan
d'action sur deux ans et que ce soit
siffler si fructueux qui est tellement
d'idées et ça je vais recommencer après
avec les partenaires du cabinet mais
surtout cette expérience vous pourriez
dire c'est la mienne mais c'est aussi
l'expérience de tous les dirigeants que
j'ai accompagné depuis et toutes les
équipes que j'ai accompagné depuis à
faire un pas de côté ce pas côté de la
confiance
mais pas côté de la confiance il est
important
mais enlève pas la solitude qu'on
ressent cette solitude de dirigeants
quand il faut prendre des décisions
courageuses
alors ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
créé un environnement où tous ces
décideurs tous ces leaders collectif
pourrait se retrouver le single il était
né et il a permis à beaucoup de
dirigeants de venir partager leur
expérience de donner leurs forces mais
aussi de partager puisque c'était en
toute intimité
c'est en toute confiance
dans un cadre sécurisé leurs difficultés
les questions qui leur posaient les
transformations les pas qu'il avait
encore à faire
alors tout ça je découvre chaque jour je
découvre encore je rencontre tous ces
gens je continue d accompagner et là se
dessine
vraiment ce paradigme du nouveau leader
alors maintenant vous demandez sûrement
quels sont les trois clics je vous
annonce son entrée la première risque de
vous surprendre puisqu'elle va à
l'encontre de toutes les images d'epinal
la première clé dont j'ai envie de vous
parler ce soir c'est l'humilité
l'humilité c'est très puissant
parce que comme le dit michel landel
pour être un bon dirigeant
pour être un bon leader il faut une
certaine humilité
nous avons tous besoin des autres et
personne a réponse à tout il me réussit
très important de continuer en
permanence à bien se connaître
il faut être authentique ne pas se
mentir et rester soi même avec ses
forces et ses faiblesses qu'il faut
aussi savoir montrer parce
qu'effectivement pour moi un leader
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a ses
imperfections et c'est quelqu'un qui
sait que être parfait c'est pas vraiment
intéressant parce que c'est toutes nos
imperfections se sont toutes nos
vulnérabilités qui font nous ce que l'on
est dans toute l'humanité que l'on a
c'est ça qui fait qu'on peut s'ouvrir
aux autres qu'on n'a pas peur de l'autre
parce que si on s'accepte soi même on
peut accepter l'autre comme on est c'est
cette humilité aussi qui nous faire
connaître le pouvoir de choix qu'on a
nous avons tous en effet le haut le
choix de pouvoir choisir la façon dont
nous regardons le monde et ça c'est une
leçon essentielle
il a ainsi possible de dire qu'on peut
accéder à des postes de responsabilité
tout en restant soi-même y compris dans
des grandes organisations et il est
aussi possible de rêver et même de faire
en sorte que en atteignant ces postes à
responsabilité on puisse enfin agir sur
le système qu'on dénonçait avant
[Musique]
la deuxième clé que j'aimerais partager
avec vous sur ce nouvel art du pouvoir
et se leaders collectif c'est la
confiance la confiance c'est quelque
chose de très profond
la confiance comme le dit jean dominique
senard président du groupe michelin
la confiance c'est profond la vraie
confiance c'est donner l'autonomie à des
équipes et on est en même temps c'est
dire à chacun qu'il est responsable de
ses actes ça va dans les deux sens je te
donne quelque chose mais en retour
tu me dois quelque chose et tu vois
surtout quelque chose à l'équipe au
projet à l'entreprise la confiance c'est
quelque chose de très profond
c'est un peu comme marc la révolution
copernicienne
copernic a annoncé en 15 143 que la
terre tourne autour du soleil
ça paraît une évidence aujourd'hui au
21ème siècle
mais quand il l'a fait il lui a fallu un
certain courage parce que s'étaient
affrontées toute l'église et tous les
systèmes de croyances de l'époque
d'ailleurs il a mis 36 ans avant de
révéler ses découvertes 36 ans et
quelque chose et aujourd'hui il faut à
peu près même courage aux leaders
collectif pour dire que la performance
tourne autour la confiance et dans l'
inverse
parce que c'est bien un nouveau
paradigme dont il s'agit tous nos
systèmes seront à peu près monté sur l'
inverse
c'est la confiance qui au coeur et ça
c'est important
et la confiance ça marche
j'aurais pas le temps de vous raconter
en détail l'expérience de cette équipe
mais j'ai quand même vous dire quelques
quelques mots de leur histoire
il était dans un marché à -15% par an du
coup qu'est ce qui se passait chacun
disait que c'était la faute de l'autre
il y avait
une désunion totale plus de confiance et
pourtant il a suffi de deux jours deux
jours de séminaire pour que tout le
monde se reparlent tout le monde
retrouve confiance en soi et trouve
confiance en l'équipe et on a même
prolongé sa deux autres jours de
séminaire
ils ont refait l'intégralité de leur
vision et de leur programme pour
atteindre et clients ils ont remis cette
confiance qu'ils avaient retrouvé au
centre de la relation avec leurs clients
résultat sur deux ans 26 % de ventes en
plus à équipe constante
la confiance ça marche alors maintenant
je voudrais vous partager la troisième
clé de ce leader collectif et cette clé
c'est l'essence on a parfois un petit
peu de peine à évoquer sens parce qu'il
est tellement écrit partout dans des
logos dans des slogans sur les murs les
murs affiché partout et finalement
souvent on a l'impression qu'il n'est
pas vraiment là dans les faits et
pourtant ce sens c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel
parce qu'on est dans un monde de
changement sans échapper à aucun d'entre
vous comme dit henri lachmann ancien
directeur général de schneider electric
et mon du comité des sages de rustines
khalid le changement est permanent il
n'ya rien son changement et on n'a que
le choix entre le changement que l'on
initie où les changements que l'on subit
et la différence entre les changements
qu'on initie et les changements qu'ils
ont subi c'est le sens que l'on donne
aux choses le sens que l'on donne à
l'action alors on passe enfin de cette
petite peur pour son petit soin qu'est
ce qui va se passer avec ce changement
pour moi à l'intérêt général
je suis capable de contribuer je suis
capable d'avancer parce que c'est ainsi
que j'ai participé à changer
l'entreprise a changé le monde pour le
meilleur et ça c'est un véritable
changement de paradigme
parce qu'alors vous changer de logique
où je gagne du père forcément dû ou à
une logique de et de win win
et si on gagner plus ensemble alors on
peut vraiment challenge et le statu quo
comme steve jobs ce moi aussi je crois
qu'on peut penser différemment et moi
aussi je crois que c'est ce qu'ils sont
vraiment assez fou pour haut-rhin croire
que c'est possible que qu'on peut
changer le monde qui sont ceux qui le
font
alors ce soir si j'ai partagé ses trois
idées avec vous c'est vraiment pour que
vous reteniez qu'on peut changer le
monde en étant leader qui donne du sens
parce que l'entreprise à mes yeux c'est
vraiment la plus belle ong du monde
c'est celle qui est la solution à
beaucoup de défis qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui encore faut-il qu'on le
reconnaisse et qu'on agisse qu'on sache
mobiliser les acteurs et c'est autour de
ce sens qu'on peut mobiliser les acteurs
et autour de cette notion de création de
valeur partagée cher à porter et que
j'aime moi aussi beaucoup la confiance
bien sûr je vous en ai parlé la
confiance en soi d'abord parce qu'on a
un compte
on a conscience qu'on partage à quelque
chose de beau on fait partie de quelque
chose de grand et la confiance en
l'équipe parce que tous ensemble on peut
aller vraiment plus loin et on est
vraiment plus fort et enfin cette
troisième clé au coeur de tout eh si
j'avais eu en a incité qu'une seule des
dix règles que j'ai défini dans mon
prochain livre sur le leader collectif
j'aurais choisi celle là l'humilité
parce que vraiment c'est celle qui vous
permet de comprendre que plus vous allez
de l'intérieur puis vous découvrez la
vraie personne que vous êtes au vrai
talent votre coeur et puis vous aurez
d'impact sur l'extérieur puis vous serez
capable de marcher votre parole de walk
the talk
alors je vous encourage aussi à être en
c1 de ces milliers de personnes de leur
collectif et à vous aussi construire
demain à l'image de vos valeurs et de
vos rêves
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]